สวัสดีค่ะครูอ้อยสวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กและ
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกๆคนนะคะ
ขอต้อนรับนะคะ
นักเรียนทุกคนเข้าสู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทยแบบ
ธรรมชาติ competable ไทยค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ใน
วันนี้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กกับครูอ้อยก็มาพบกับ
ทุกๆคนอีกแล้วค่ะวันอะไรคะวันนี้เนี่ยวัน
จันทร์ค่ะครูอ้อย
วันจันทร์ที่วันที่ 4 นะคะเดือนอะไรครับ
ครูอ้อยเดือนกันยายนค่ะเดือนกันยายนเป็น
เดือนที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 9
ปีพ.ศที่เท่าไหร่คะปีพุทธศักราชหรือพ.ศ
ที่
2566 ค่ะ
นะ
2023 ค่ะหรือค.ศ
ครูอ้อยมาพบกับทุกคนในวันจันทร์วันที่ 4
เดือนกันยายนค่ะนะเป็นเดือนที่ 9 นะปี
พุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสต์ศักราช 2023 ค่ะนะ
เป็นยังไงคะครูอ้อยวันนี้เราเจอกันเนี่ย 2
รอบเลยค่ะไหนๆเราไม่เจอกันนาน
ปุ๊กับแกล้งครูอ้อย
ครูอ้อยไม่ค่อยได้มาวันนี้เลยจับครูอ้อย
แกล้งเลยใช่ไหม
หนูอ้อยเนี่ยเออทำให้พี่ปุ๊กเนี่ยคิดถึง
เมื่อก่อนเลยค่ะ
นะคิดถึงเมื่อก่อนเพราะครูปุ๊กเนี่ยชอบ
แกล้งคน
แกล้งใครคะ
คนดี
ไม่เชื่อนักเรียนอยากไปเชื่อปุ๊กเนี่ยชอบ
แกล้งคนแกล้งมาตั้งแต่สมัยเราเรียนเป็น
นักศึกษาอยู่มหาวิทยาลัย
รามคำแหงอ๋อโอ๊ยกูอ้อยนะคืออย่างนี้นัก
เรียน
เราเรียนมหาวิทยาลัยเดียวกัน
พักอยู่ที่เดียวกันเพราะเรามาจากจังหวัด
ชลบุรีเหมือนกัน
แล้วก็ครูชิกับครูอ้อยเนี่ยเขาเป็นเพื่อน
กันค่ะ
ครูอ้อยแล้วเราก็ไปอยู่อพาร์ทเม้นท์ด้วย
กันนะจะเราสนิทกันมากๆเนาะเราก็ชี้ออกไป
ค่ะ
อ๋อไล่ออกจากไล่ออกจากที่พักแล้วเราอยู่
กันสองคน
น่าสงสาร Gucci เนาะ
เขาอยากเรียนเร็วไง
เรียนจบเร็วเขาก็เลยออกไปเร็วจนจบก่อนครู
อ้อยด้วยแล้วเขาก็ไปก่อน
นะเราก็เลยได้อยู่ด้วยกันค่ะแล้วก็เป็น
ความสนุกที่ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยรู้สึกแบบชอบมากๆ
มีความสุขทุกครั้งที่คิดถึงค่ะครูอ้อย
เพราะว่าเราอยู่กันสองคนแล้วเป็นห้องยิ่ง
ใหญ่ที่สุดในหอพักในพาร์ทเม้นท์นั้นใช่
ค่ะนะแล้วก็ให้ห้องพักเราเป็นห้องที่ใหญ่
ที่สุดเลยนะ
ใช่เพราะว่าจริงๆแล้วอ่ะต้องมี 4 คนค่ะ
สำหรับ 4 คนนะมีเตียงสำหรับนอนเนี่ยนะ 4
เตียงอยู่ในห้อง
แต่เราอยู่กันกี่คนครูปุ๊กตอนแรกเราอยู่
กันสองคนสองคนแล้วก็มีพี่ที่มาขออยู่ด้วย
อีก 1 คนเพราะว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยน่ารักค่ะ
น่ารักด้วยต้องน่ารักทั้งสองคน
พี่หนึ่งคนก็เลยมาขออยู่ด้วยก็เลยก็โอเค
ค่ะ
นะเราก็เลยอยู่กันนะ 3 คนค่ะ
นะ
แล้วก็
นักเรียนมันเป็นเตียงนอน
ทำให้แบบเขียนกระดานไม่สะดวกเลยอ่ะ
ทำไมอ่ะคะ
กระดานกุ๊กๆมันๆค่ะ
เมื่อกี้
สอนไปกินปาท่องโก๋อ้อยเห็นใครค่ะกุ๊กๆดู
สนุกสนานกับการสอนปาท่องโก๋มากแล้วมือก็
มันก็ไปจับกระดานก็ได้ก็มันใช่นะหมึกก็
เลยไม่ติดเลยเฮ้อแล้วกูปุ๊บก็เป็นคนที่
วาดรูปเก่งที่สุดครูอ้อยก็วาดรูปไม่เป็น
เพราะฉะนั้นครูปุ๊กก็เลยต้องพยายามวาดรูป
ห้องพักที่เราพักกันตอนสมัยเรียน
มหาวิทยาลัย
คือห้องเนี่ยมันเป็นห้องใหญ่นะนักเรียน
แล้วก็มีเตียงทั้งหมดเนี่ย 4 เตียง
นักเรียนนึกภาพตามครูเอออันนี้ได้ค่ะ
[เพลง]
ตอนที่เรามาอยู่ใหม่ๆเนี่ย
ห้องนี้ 4 เตียงก็จริงแต่ครูปุ๊กกับครู
อ้อยอยู่กันแค่ 2 คนนะคะ
อยู่เมื่อหลายเดือนแล้ว
อยู่มาหลายเดือนแล้วก็โอ้โหแฮปปี้มาก
เพราะสนุกมากสุขมากที่สุดเพราะว่าห้อง
ใหญ่แล้วก็อยู่กันอย่างสบายอากาศดีด้วย
ค่ะเพราะว่ามันไม่ได้หยุดติดถนนนักเรียน
เราเข้าไปในซอยแล้วณห้องนอนของเราเนี่ย
หน้าต่างเยอะมากใช่ค่ะ
ประตู
เปิดประตูเข้ามาที่นี่ค่ะ
อันนี้จะเป็นตู้สำหรับใส่เสื้อผ้าค่ะ
นะ 1 ตู้เพราะว่าสำหรับเตียง 1 เตียงก็ 1
ตู้ 1 เตียงก็ 1 ตู้ 1 เตียงก็ 1 ตู้ 1
เตียงก็ 1 ตู้
แล้วก็จะมีโต๊ะค่ะอันนี้เป็นโต๊ะ
โต๊ะเขียนหนังสือโต๊ะอ่านหนังสืออันนี้ก็
เป็นโต๊ะ
โต๊ะ
แล้วก็อันนี้ก็โต๊ะ
ไม่ได้บอกทำไมอันนี้มีอยู่แค่ 3 โต๊ะ
อันนี้จะยาวกว่าคนอื่นค่ะ
[เพลง]
แล้วก็เตียงยาวออกมาอย่างนี้
ใช่ไหมมันก็จะเป็น
เป็นแบบนี้ค่ะ
นะแล้วก็เราอยู่กัน 3 คนตอนแรกเนี่ย 2 คน
ครู Google ที่นี่ค่ะครูกุ๊กๆอืม
ครูอ้อยนอนที่นี่
แล้วก็เราก็เลยใช้เตียงตรงกลางเนี่ยเป็น
โต๊ะอาหารค่ะ
ใช่
ค่อยวางอาหารในการ
เตียงมันก็ไม่สูงนะนักเรียนนั่งลงก็เป็น
เหมือนโต๊ะพอดีนะ
ก็มีรุ่นพี่ก็มาอยู่เตียงข้างล่างเนี่ย
ที่ครูกำลังว่า
ก็เป็นพี่นัท
ก็อยู่กัน 3 คนเนาะ
นี่ก็ผู้หญิงนะคะเพราะว่าทั้งหมดเป็นผู้
หญิงหอพักผู้หญิงค่ะ
แล้วก็
อยู่กันแบบสนุกมาก
มีอะไรให้เล่นให้สนุกทุกวัน
พอพูดถึงแกล้งเนี่ยคิดถึงน้องคนนึง
นะ
ทุกๆลบก่อนนะลบทิ้งแล้วนะ
เพราะว่าคิดถึงน้องที่แบบมาสนิท
นะเขาเรียกว่าสนิทก็คือรู้จักกันแล้วก็
เอ่อน้องคนนี้
พูดคุยกันได้เยอะ
แล้วก็ไปไหนด้วยกันออกไปซื้อของด้วยกัน
กลับมาจากมหาวิทยาลัยก็มานั่งคุยกันกิน
ข้าวด้วยกัน
พอสนิทกันใช่สนิทกันเนี่ยก็น้องคนนี้เขา
อยู่ห้องห้องที่หัดเราไปเนี่ย 2 ห้องนะ 1
2 ห้องก็จะเป็นผู้หญิง 1 คน
อยู่กับน้องสาวเค้าใช่มั้ยครูปุ๊กอ๋อใช่
เขาต้องอยู่ 2 คนอืมก็ห้องเขาเนี่ยจริงๆ
แล้วมี 3 เตียง
อืมที่นอนเนี่ย 3  3 เตียงและแต่เขาอยู่
กันแค่ 2 คนแล้วทีนี้เนี่ยตอนนั้นเนี่ยมี
น้องสาวมาจากต่างจังหวัดอืมไม่ได้อยู่
กรุงเทพฯเขามาสอบเอ็นทรานซ์เข้า
มหาวิทยาลัย
น้องเนี่ยชื่อบี
2 คนเนี่ยเป็นพี่น้องกัน
น้องเนี่ยมาอายุ 18 ใช่ไหม
ก็
กำลังเรียน High  School จบก็จะเรียนสมัย
ก่อนมันสอบเอ็นทานเนาะก็ต้องมาที่
กรุงเทพฯ
ไม่ได้มาคนเดียว
มีเพื่อนมาด้วย 1 คนใช่ค่ะ
ก็เป็นผู้หญิงมาด้วยคนนึงใช่เพื่อนผู้
หญิงคนนี้ชื่อทีละกัน
อ่า
ชื่อติ๊ก
2 คนเนี่ยเป็นเพื่อนกัน
แล้วก็คนนี้เนี่ยเขาบอกว่าเขาต้องมาสอบ
เอนทรานซ์ที่กรุงเทพฯนะฮะแต่ไม่มีที่พัก
บีก็เลยบอกโอเคมา
มาอยู่ด้วยกัน
ก็เลยมาด้วยกัน 2 คนอายุ 18 เท่ากันสอบ
Entrance ที่กรุงเทพฯสอบเข้ามหาวิทยาลัย
เนาะ
แล้วทีนี้เนี่ย
จริงๆเนี่ยไม่รู้จักครูปุ๊กไม่รู้จักครู
อ้อย
เพราะว่า
มีแต่ a เนี่ยที่จะสนิทกับครูปุ๊กครูอ้อย
แล้วก็จะมาที่ห้องนะห้องพักแล้วก็มานั่ง
กินข้าวด้วยกันที่เตียงกัน
ทุกวันเลยเราจะไปเจอกันทุกวันตอนเย็นหลัง
จากกลับจากมหาวิทยาลัยแล้วใครถือของกินมา
ก็จะมานั่งกินกันที่บ้านที่ห้องเรา
ขนมปังไข่ดาวนะเป็นเซตอาหารฝรั่ง
a ก็จะมากินด้วยนะแต่พอดีกับติ๊กมาก็
ต้องเรียกมากินด้วยกันไงก็มาเพิ่มมาอีก 2
ใช่ก็พอมากินด้วยกันเนาะนะ
เป็นเด็กนะก็น่ารักนะ
แต่ข้อเสียของเขาเนี่ยก็คือเขาเป็นคนไม่
ชอบขออนุญาต
ใช่ไหมปกติเนี่ยถ้าเราเนอะจะเข้าห้อง
อย่างถ้าครูปุ๊กกับครูอ้อยเนี่ยมีห้องคน
ละห้องใช่ไหมครูอ้อยก็มีห้องครูอ้อยครู
ปุ๊กก็มีห้องครูปุ๊กเวลาครูปุ๊กเจอขอเข้า
ห้องกูอ้อยเนี่ย
เชิญค่ะหรือว่าเข้ามาได้หรือว่าเข้ามาเลย
อันนี้ก็โอเคใช่ไหม
นะก็ควรจะต้องเคาะประตูใช่ไหม
แต่บางทีเนี่ยครูปุ๊กครูอ้อยอยู่ในห้อง
อ่ะแต่ห้องเดียวกันเนาะนะเพราะว่าอยู่
ด้วยกัน 2 คนแต่ติ๊กเนี่ย
ไม่ได้มากับ a กับ B นะติ๊กมาคนเดียวมา
ห้องเราใช่แล้วก็ครูอ้อยเปิดประตูเข้ามา
เลย
แล้วก็ลงมาแล้วก็นั่งแล้วก็กินขนมของครู
ปุ๊กครูอ้อย
กินไม่ขออนุญาตใช่ไหมปกติเนี่ยถ้าเป็นขนม
ครูอ้อยซื้อมาครูอ้อยมีเงินจ่ายเงินซื้อ
ครูอ้อยก็เป็นเจ้าของขนม
ถ้าครูปุ๊กจะกินครูปุ๊กก็จะบอกครูอ้อยกิน
ได้ไหมอันนี้
แล้วครูอ้อยบอกว่ากินได้อันนี้โอเคอันนี้
ขออนุญาตใช่ไหมหรือครูปุ๊กบอกครูอ้อยขอ
ขนมอันนี้ได้ไหมแล้วครูอ้อยบอกว่าโอเคได้
เอามากินได้ถูกไหม
อันเนี้ยครูปุ๊ปขออนุญาตแต่ถ้าครูปุ๊กมา
แล้วก็หยิบแล้วก็กินอันนี้ไม่ได้ขออนุญาต
แต่ติ๊กเนี่ยไม่ขออนุญาตนะเดินๆมาแล้วก็
เปิดประตูแอ๊ดเข้ามา
แล้วก็ลงมานั่ง
ตรงเตียงตรงกลางเนาะ
ขนมของครูอ้อยเนี่ยแล้วก็กิน
ไม่ขออนุญาตไม่ขอว่าติ๊กกินได้ไหมน้องกิน
ได้ไหมหรือว่าอยากขอกินได้ไหมอะไรอย่าง
นี้ไม่พูดหยิกแล้วก็กินเลย
แต่
ครูปุ๊กก็รู้สึกแบบไม่ดีนะ
2 คนเนี่ยโอเคไม่เป็นไรของกินกินได้
ควรเราจะยังไม่ได้ว่าอะไร
ใช่นะ
เราก็ให้เขาน้องกินแหละ
ใช่
แต่มีวันนึงนั้นนักเรียนเกิดเหตุการณ์น่ะ
เกิดเหตุการณ์ที่ครูปุ๊กสามารถแกล้งน้อง
ได้
ครูปุ๊บกลับบ้านที่ชลบุรี
บ้านครูปุ๊กไม่ได้อยู่กรุงเทพฯนะเมื่อ
ก่อน
นะแล้วชลบุรีเนี่ยมีขนมอร่อยค่ะที่ที่
อื่นก็ไม่ค่อยมีนะ
นะมีหลายอย่างกูก็เลยซื้อขนมมาค่ะ
นี่ค่ะอันนี้ก็จะเป็น
แล้วก็มีข้าวเกรียบอันนี้แหละอร่อยแล้ว
ไม่มีที่อื่นขายใช่ต้องชลบุรี
ของโปรดครูอ้อย
นี่ขนมก้นถั่ว
ใช่ค่ะข้างล่างเนี่ยเป็นถั่ว
นะมันเป็นถ้วยเล็กๆเนาะแล้วก็ข้างล่างเขา
ก็เลยเรียกว่ามันก้นถ้วยไงเป็นก้น
ถั่วก้นเป็นถั่ว
อร่อย
[เพลง]
มันมีขนมหลายอย่างเนาะ
ซื้อขนมมา
วันนั้นเนี่ยกลับบ้านที่ชลบุรีแล้วก็ซื้อ
ขนมมา
นะเสร็จแล้วครูปุ๊กก็เข้ามาวางไว้ที่โต๊ะ
แล้วก็เรียกครูอ้อยมากิน
เค้าเรียก
พี่นัท
ที่อยู่ในห้องเดียวกันเนาะอยู่ชั้น 3 คน
ตอนนั้น
ก็เรียกมากิน
ทุกอย่างใส่จานเรียบร้อย
ใส่ยังตอนนั้นคือแกะออกมากำลังแกะออกมา
เนี่ยพี่นัทก็อยู่ๆก็บอกวิ่งลงไปรับ
โทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมเมื่อก่อนไม่มีโทรศัพท์มือ
ถือนะไม่มีโทรศัพท์แบบนี้ไม่มีค่ะต้อง
เป็นโทรศัพท์ที่หอพักอพาร์ทเม้นท์ต้องลง
ไปแล้วพี่นัทเนี่ยไปรับโทรศัพท์แล้วก็
วิ่งขึ้นมาแล้วก็อ้อยปุ๊บมาเร็วๆ
ไปไปกับพี่ไปกับพี่
จะกลับมาจากบ้านเพิ่งจะถึงหอยังนั่งเนี่ย
ไม่ 1 ชั่วโมงเลยยังไม่ครึ่งชั่วโมงเลย
กำลังจะกินขนมด้วยใช่แต่ว่าพี่นัทเนี่ยก็
รีบมากเลยบอกไปเร็วๆไปกินพิซซ่า
โตแล้วตอนนี้
พิซซ่าเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนไม่มีไม่มีร้าน
พิซซ่า
นะไม่มีเนาะที่ไทยเนี่ยตอนนี้ยังมี 11  12
เอ่อใช่มั้ย
พิซซ่าฮัทไม่มีค่ะยังไม่มีตอนนั้นนะก็พี่
นัทก็ชวนเร็วๆไปกินพิซซ่าโอ้โห 2 คนทิ้ง
ขนมเลยค่ะวางไว้เลยค่ะ
เร็วๆๆเพื่อนกำลังจะทำพิซซ่าคือพี่นัท
เนี่ยเขาเขามีเพื่อนเป็นฝรั่ง
เป็นอะไรอ่ะสอนศาสนาเนอะเกี่ยวกับศาสนา
คริสต์ใช่ไหมนะแล้วก็พี่นัทเนี่ยเขาไปนับ
ถือศาสนาคริสต์แล้วเขาก็บอกว่าเพื่อน
เนี่ยจะทำพิซซ่าไปเร็วๆเร็วๆเดี๋ยวกิน
ก่อนพี่นัทบอกไม่ต้องกินไม่ต้องกินไป
เดี๋ยวนี้ไปเดี๋ยวนี้ก็จับ 2 คนเนี่ยไป
เลยครูปุ๊ก็บอกนี่ไม่ได้เก็บเลย
ไนท์บอกไม่เป็นไรเดี๋ยวมาไปกินพิซซ่าก่อน
เดี๋ยวกลับมาครูก็คิดอ๋อคิดว่าน่าจะเป็น
ซอยใกล้ๆเนาะ
ไม่ใช่ค่ะนักเรียน
ไปถนนสุขุมวิทเนอะ
แล้วสมัยนั้นไม่มีรถไฟฟ้าค่ะ
มีแต่รถเมล์ค่ะนั่งรถเมล์ไปโอ้ยไกล
นะแต่รถเมล์ต่อเดียวไง
แล้วก็ไปเนี่ยเพื่อนพี่นัทเนี่ยเขาก็ทำ
พิซซ่าแล้วเป็นฝรั่งเออพูดภาษาอังกฤษไม่
ได้เนาะก็อ้า
Thank  You  Thank  You  Thank  You
very  much
พอกินเสร็จก็ Thank  You  Thank  You
ตอนนั้นเนี่ยต้องไปช่วยเขาทำก่อนค่ะ
นักเรียนใจเรื่องกินแต่ครูอ้อยเนี่ยเขาสน
ใจเรื่องทำพิซซ่าค่ะเขามีกระดาษมีสมุด
เนาะมีปากกานะแล้วก็ไปจดมีกระดาษสมุดแล้ว
ก็จดๆๆทำยังไงใช่ไหมแป้งอะไรทำยังไงเสร็จ
แล้วเนี่ยทีนี้เนี่ย
เอ่อ
ฝรั่งคนนั้นน่ะเพื่อนเพื่อนพี่นัทเนี่ย
เขาก็
เอ่อเอาแป้งพิซซ่าเอ้ยไม่ใช่แป้งสิอะไรนะ
ครูอ้อย
ยีสต์อ๋อยี้ใส่แป้งเออ
ยีสต์ที่มันเราทำใส่แป้งอ่ะตอนที่หมักให้
มันฟูอ่ะอืมเนาะเขาต้องใส่ยีสต์ลงไปกับ
แป้งเนอะแล้วก็นวดแล้วก็เก็บทิ้งไว้ใช่
ไหมให้แป้งเนี่ยมันฟูขึ้น
แล้วทีนี้เนี่ยเขาก็มีถุงเป็นซองฟอยล์
เล็กๆเนาะใช่ๆมันไม่ได้เป็นขวดเหมือนสมัย
นี้นะมันเป็นซองเล็กๆซองเล็กกว่านี้อีก
ครูปุ๊กใช่แต่ว่าไปหารูปไม่เจอ
เอาซองปอยมาให้ดูว่าซองมันเป็นลักษณะแบบ
นี้แต่เล็กๆนักเรียนเล็กมาก
นะ
เป็นซองเล็กขนาดแบบแค่นี้
แล้วก็มีชื่อเนอะชื่อภาษาอังกฤษ
ครูปูก็จำไม่ได้แล้วเนาะนะเพราะว่าครู
อ้อยเป็นคนอยากได้ค่ะซองมันประมาณเนี้ย
ค่ะแล้วก็มีชื่อภาษาอังกฤษอยู่ประมาณแค่
เนี้ยมันเป็นภาษาอังกฤษ
ซองเล็กๆ
ครูอ้อยก็บอกว่าขอ
ขอซองขอซองปอยเนี่ยเพราะว่าเอออยากได้
เพราะว่าครูอ้อยเนี่ยจดว่าต้องซื้ออะไร
ครูอ้อยอยากทำพิซซ่า
ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยไม่สนใจบอกแล้ว
ไม่คิดทำพิซซ่าค่ะครูอ้อยก็ขอซองก่อนมา 1
ซอง
เวลาไปซื้อจะได้รู้ไงว่ายี่ห้ออะไรนะมัน
มีชื่อภาษาอังกฤษเขียนอยู่
นะแล้วครูอ้อยเนี่ยเขาก็จะเอาซองปอยเนี่ย
เก็บใส่กระเป๋า
แตกครูอ้อยไม่มีอะไรไปค่ะไม่
เสื้อก็ไม่มีกระเป๋าใส่ไม่มีกางเกงก็ไม่
มีกระเป๋าใส่นะก็ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมีเสื้อตัว
ใหญ่แล้วก็มีกระเป๋ากระเป๋ากระเป๋าเยอะ
ครูอ้อยก็เลยบอกว่าเอาซองฟอยล์เนี่ยฝาก
ครูปุ๊กบอกปุ๊บ
เอาฝากไว้หน่อย
นะพี่อ้อยไม่มีกระเป๋าใส่
สมมุติว่าโอเคเอามาก็ใส่ไว้ในกระเป๋า
เสื้อ
ทีนี้เนี่ยเราก็ไปรอรถเมล์กัน
นะรถประจำทาง
นะฮะ
ก็รออยู่สักพักนึงครูปุ๊กก็เลยคุยกับพี่
นัทแล้วก็ครูอ้อยเนาะว่า
ครูอ้อยเริ่มคิดถึงขนมที่อยู่ที่ห้อง
ครูอ้อย
ครูอ้อยว่าเราเนี่ย 2 คนไม่อยู่ห้อง 3 คน
รวมพี่นัท 3 คนไม่อยู่ห้องเนี่ยครูอ้อย
คิดว่าติ๊กเนี่ยจะเข้ามาที่ห้องไหมแล้ว
ติ๊กเนี่ยจะกินขนมที่ครูกุ๊กเอามาหรือ
เปล่า
เออเพราะว่าติ๊กยังไม่รู้ว่าครูกุ๊กซื้อ
ขนมมา
แต่ถ้าติ๊กเปิดประตูเข้าไปก็จะเห็นขนมเลย
นะ
ใช่แต่เราไม่อยู่กันเลยนะ
แต่ว่าครูปุ๊กก็คิดเอ้อติ๊กเนี่ยจะต้อง
กินขนมครกแน่ๆแต่ตอนนั้นครูอ้อยยังคิดว่า
ไม่นะ
ครูอ้อยก็บอกไม่หรอกโอ้โหนะคนมันแบบว่า
เจ้าของห้องไม่อยู่จะเข้าไปแล้วไปกินหรอ
ไม่หรอกอืมครูอ้อยก็บอกไม่หรอกพี่นัทก็
บอกไม่หรอกคือแบบเอาอย่างนี้ไหมเริ่มมี
ไอเดียปิ้งเริ่มมีแผล
ก็บอกว่าเอาอย่างนี้เดี๋ยวพอไปถึงถ้าถึง
อพาร์ทเม้นท์หอพักเนาะนะ
แล้วคุยกันว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยใส่ยาวไว้ในขนม
นะฮะ
ใช่ๆๆเพราะครูอ้อยแบบขวดจริงจบ
ครูอ้อยเขากลัวจิ้งจกก็เลยบอกว่าเอาอย่าง
นี้เดี๋ยวเราจะหลอกหรือว่าแกล้งน้องโกหก
ว่านะครูปุ๊กเนี่ยใส่ยาที่ขนมเพราะว่ามัน
เปิดไว้ไง
เขากลัวตัวนี้ค่ะนักเรียน
เขากลัวจิ้งจกมากๆนะเป็นตัวเล็กๆนะแต่
นะครูอ้อยเขาแบบไม่รู้เขาเกลียดมากกลัว
มากนะครูก็เลยบอกว่า
วางแผนเลยนะตั้งแต่ยังไม่ขึ้นรถเมล์อ่ะ
ยังไม่ขึ้นรถประจำทางกูก็บอกว่าครูปุ๊ก
ว่าน้องเนี่ยต้องเข้ามาในห้องแล้วก็กิน
ขนมหรือไม่จริงไม่หลอกไม่หลอกพี่นัทก็ไม่
คือแบบเอาอย่างนี้ถ้าไปถึงนะ
ถ้าไปถึงแล้วเนี่ยถึงหอพักถึง
อพาร์ทเม้นท์เนี่ยนะเราคุยกันนะว่าครู
ปุ๊กใส่เคมีดีๆทีลงไปในขนมสำหรับฆ่า
จิ้งจกเพราะว่าอ้อยเนี่ยไม่ชอบจิ้งจกมากๆ
ก็เลยพูดกันอย่างนี้นะก็เตรียมไว้พอไปถึง
ปุ๊บนะตอนนั้นก็เย็นแล้วนะ
ติ๊กก็ได้ยินเสียงพวกเราเนี่ยไปถึงเราก็
คุยใช่ไหมพอไปเจอแม่บ้านแม่บ้านอ้าวกลับ
มาแล้วหรอเป็นยังไงพิซซ่าอร่อยไหมอะไร
อย่างนี้ติ๊กเนี่ยอยู่ข้างบนได้ยินก็วิ่ง
ลงมาแล้วก็อ้าพี่ๆกลับมาแล้ว
มองหน้าครูอ้อยแล้วคุณปุ๊กก็บอกว่า
เออไม่รู้ว่าตอนนี้เนี่ยจิ้งจกเนี่ยตาย
กี่ตัวแล้ว
ที่ห้องใช่นะติ๊กก็จิ้งจกตายอะไรหรอ
ก็เลยบอกอ๋อ
ก็พี่เนี่ยใส่ดีๆทีใส่เคมี
ในขนม
ที่วางอยู่ที่เตียง
ให้จิ้งจกกินจิ้งจกกินจิ้งจกก็ตาย
หน้าเนี่ยเปลี่ยนครูก็รู้และ
กินแน่ๆ
ใช่มั้ย
ก็เลยเดินไปแล้วก็คุยกันไปครูอ้อยก็บอก
อ่ะครูอ้อยก็เล่นด้วยครูอ้อยก็บอกเออไม่
รู้ว่าตายหมดหรือยังรถจิ้งจกเนี่ยนะครูก็
บอกเฮ้ย
มันน่าจะต้องมากินมันต้องตายแหละตายหมด
ทุกตัวแหละ
นะก็คุยกันไปแต่ว่าห้องเราอยู่ชั้นที่ 2
ก็ต้องขึ้นบันไดระหว่างขึ้นบันไดเนี่ย
ติ๊กเขาเดินมาด้วยเขาได้ยินครูปุ๊บครู
อ้อยพี่นัทคุยกันเรื่องจิ้งจกตายเพราะว่า
ใส่เคมีในขนม
ครูก็เดินแต่ติ๊กเนี่ยไม่ได้เดินธรรมดา
นักเรียน
เขาเดินลงส้นเท้าเสียงดัง
แล้วก็หน้าแบบ
จิ้งจกอ่ะจะไม่ตายหรอกคนน่ะจะตาย
เขาก็พูดแบบนี้ค่ะจิ้งจกให้ตายแต่คนน่ะจะ
ตายนักเรียนเข้าใจไหมความหมายคืออะไร
เรารู้แล้วว่ากินแน่ๆ
เขากินแน่นอน
อืมใช่มั้ยครูก็เริ่มแบบเออก็หัวเราะนะ
เขาก็แบบเออไม่จริงแน่เลยโกหกใช่ไหม
เฮ้ยไม่โกหกหนูก็ลวงกระเป๋าแบบเออเจอซอง
ปล่อยยึดครูก็เลยเอามาแล้วก็บอกจริงไม่
ได้โกหกนี่ไง
ซองเคมียังอยู่เลย
เขาก็
ไหนเอามาดูเอามาดูเขาก็แย่งกับครูกุ๊ก
กุ๊กก็ไม่อยากให้ดูเพราะว่ากลัวเขาเขียน
ว่ายีสต์
ควรจะเห็นใช่แต่พอเขาแย่งไปได้น่ะก็คือ
เขากลัวไงเขาก็เลยแบบโอ้โหออกแรงเยอะแล้ว
ก็แย่งซองไปแล้วก็ดูแต่ทีนี้เนี่ยมันไม่
ได้เขียนไว้ยีสต์มันเป็นยี่ห้อเป็นชื่อ
ของแบรนด์
ยี่ห้อเขาก็อ่านแล้วก็อ่านไม่เข้าใจเพราะ
ว่าเราไม่รู้จักยีสต์กันเนาะไม่ได้ทำขนม
ปังไม่ได้ทำพิซซ่ากันก็ไม่เข้าใจ
เขาก็เริ่มแบบ
จริงหรอ
ใช่ก็นี่ไงก็ซองนี่ไงเขาก็เลยลองดมอื้อ
ใช่ๆหนูยิ้มกลิ่นมันก็ไม่โอเคเขาก็เลย
ยิ่งเออ
กูก็เลยบอกเอาอย่างนี้ดีไหม
ไปโรงพยาบาล
ไปให้หมอเนี่ยล้างท้องทำความสะอาดท้อง
ล้างท้อง
เขาก็
ไม่เห็นเป็นไรเลยกินมาหลาย 2-3 ชั่วโมง
แล้ว
เขาบอกเขาไม่เป็นไรนะไม่ได้รู้สึกอะไร 3
ชั่วโมงแล้วนะ
ครูปุ๊กก็บอกว่าอ๋อจิ้งจกเนี่ยมันตัวเล็ก
นะ 1 ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมงมันตายแล้ว
แต่คนเนี่ยตัวใหญ่กว่าเตียง
นะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยชั่วโมงเนี่ยมันต้อง
เยอะกว่า
ยาออกฤทธิ์ช้ากว่า
ต้องใช้เวลาเนี่ยมากกว่าอาจจะต้อง 5
ชั่วโมง
ถึงจะตายไปหาหมอไหมไปล้างท้องก่อน
จริงหรอ
คือกูก็เริ่มแบบ
จริง
นะฮะหรือ
อีกอย่างนึง
ควรจะไปดื่มน้ำเยอะๆ
น้ำเยอะๆเนี่ย
น้ำมันจะทำให้เคมีเนี่ยมันจางลง
เพราะว่าอย่างเช่นน้ำเต็มแก้วเนี่ยมีเคมี
แค่นี้น้ำเนี่ย
เคมีแค่นี้น้ำนิดหน่อยมันก็ไม่จางใช่ไหม
ต้องน้ำเยอะๆนะเคมีมันจะค่อยๆออกไป
ครูก็เลยไปดื่มน้ำเยอะๆ
เคมีมันจะได้จางมันจะได้ฉี่ออก
เคมีมันจะได้ลดลงลดลง
เดี๋ยวตายนะอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเขาก็เริ่มแบบ
กลัวก็ไม่รู้ครูก็เห็นเขาวิ่งออกไปก็นึก
ว่าไปคุยกับพี่นัทเพราะว่าพี่นัทอยู่ข้าง
ล่างเขาก็ไป
แล้วครูอ้อยก็คุยกัน
ว่า
เนี่ยต้องสอนน้องเนี่ยแหละ
นะก็เลยลงมาพักนึงลงไปดู
น้องกำลังดื่มน้ำ
ดื่มน้ำ
ครูก็เลยถาม
กี่แก้วแล้วนะ
แก้วเดียว
เนี่ยกำลังกินเนี่ยเป็นแก้วที่ 5
กูก็บอกไม่ต้องกินแล้ว
ไม่มีเคมี
เขาโกรธใหญ่เลย
โกรธแบบ
ทำไมค้างไว้ทำไมหลอกน้องนะโอกาสสอนเลยใช่
ถ้าเราถ้าพี่ใส่เคมีติ๊กตายแล้ว
ใช่ๆ
กิน
ต้องขออนุญาตต้องบอกเจ้าของก่อนว่ากินได้
ไหมต้องถาม
ถ้าอยากกินต้องขอ
กินได้ไหมไม่ใช่อยู่ๆหยิบกิน
ไม่รู้เขาใส่อะไรหรือเปล่า
ใช่ไหมถ้าครูปุ๊กใส่เคมีตอนนี้เนี่ยติ๊ก
เนี่ยตายแล้ว
อันนี้ก็คือการสอนน้องแต่ว่าแกล้งไปด้วย
เก่งเราก็มีความสนุกไปด้วย
ใช่แต่ก็อยากสอนเขาเพราะว่าเขาเป็นคนที่
ไม่ไม่ขออนุญาตนะ
ก็หยิบหยิบ 18 แล้วก็ไม่เด็กแล้วนะ
อายุ 18 แล้วนักเรียนนะเขาก็หยิบกินโดย
ที่ไม่ขออนุญาตมันไม่ได้ไงเราก็ไม่รู้
อะไรที่เขาใส่อะไรไปหรือเปล่าเราก็ไม่รู้
เนาะว่ากินได้กินไม่ได้นะหรือยังไงเนี่ย
มารยาทค่ะควรจะบอกเจ้าของว่า
ห้องก่อนเข้านะ
เข้าไปได้ไหมไม่ใช่เปิดเข้ามาเลย
แล้วลงมาจะกินก็ต้องขอกินได้ไหมคะหรือขอ
กินได้ไหมคะนะ
ถ้าเจ้าของบอกโอเคได้กิน
แต่อย่างกรณีนี้เนี่ยเจ้าของไม่อยู่ด้วย
แล้วเข้าไปกินเนี่ยก็อันตรายนะ
เพราะไม่รู้เลยว่าบางครั้งบางคนอาจจะมี
การใส่ยาเพื่อฆ่าอะไรไว้จริงๆ
ก็เลยเป็นไม่รู้ว่าน้องเนี่ยกลับไปแล้ว
เนี่ยเปลี่ยนหรือเปล่า
แต่เขาไม่อยู่แค่ชั่วคราว
ใช่มาแค่สอบนะสอบเสร็จเขาก็กลับแต่ก็ได้
บทเรียนนะอือนะแต่วันนี้ก็พูดถึงเรื่องบท
เรียนนี้การสอนเรื่องมารยาทอือการระมัด
ระวังตัวเองอืม
มันก็เลยแกล้งไปด้วยในตัว
แถมนักเรียนฟังแล้วปุ๊กๆไม่น่ากลัวไม่นะ
เขาเป็นคนดี
วันนี้เกินเวลาแล้วอ้อยไว้คราวหน้ามา
ขอบคุณมากนะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะ